ah don't you just love a good jump scare
please don't go to Nationals if we open
the door to superstition where does that
lead the woman in black stars Daniel
Radcliffe coming right off a Harry
Potter and I was really interested in
this movie for one reason in particular
I really wanted to see if Daniel
Radcliffe could give a great performance
outside of the Harry Potter world
because he's done some plays that I
guess were really successful involving
lots of nudity that I don't really know
about but I guess he was really good in
it he's matured a lot as an actor over
the course of the Harry Potter film
stars interested in seeing when he could
bring to a role that wasn't Harry Potter
I think the film takes place in the late
1800s I'm not positive but there is like
one guy and found who has a car and he's
like really famous because he has a car
everyone knows he's the guy with the car
and he sent to this house to take care
of a whole bunch of legal documents
because this woman has died and so is
her son
I feel she's that trying to reach me and
there's all these rumors around town
about this house weird things have been
seen things are going on that are creepy
and this whole murder mystery develops
around this house what happened the
woman what happened to her son what are
all these strange going on Daniel
Radcliffe has to figure that out I was
really pleased with Radcliffe in this
movie I thought he did a good job he
gave a good performance it wasn't just
the same old stuff from Harry Potter I
liked what he had to do it likely
brought to his character get a lot of
little subtle nuances with his character
he didn't overact at all he was very
very low-key which was very good the
only thing I really buy is that he has a
four-year-old kid and he just doesn't
look old enough to have a four-year-old
kid unless he had it when he was like 17
or something which is of course possible
but I really enjoy woman in black I
thought it was a good suspense film not
like out of this world terrifying but
just a very good suspense movie it
wasn't too long there's about 90 minutes
long there's a lot of jump scares at
times for the first half of the movie
and that's kind of cheap you know a lot
of birds and stuff are flying out of
holes and everything and you're just
seeing it just it gets a little bit like
a we've seen this a thousand times
let's go to something with a little more
substance I believe even the most
rational mind can play tricks the doc
who's that
once you get past the halfway point in
the film and Daniel Radcliffe spends his
first full night in this house it really
picks up in regards to scarce lots of
really good use of tension
lots of slow building moments that I
really appreciate it enjoyed the art
direction this movie is fantastic it has
a lot of old gothic looks to it going on
the house itself is really creepy they
did a good job of using those rooms the
strange little dolls and little toys
that move to showing their faces the
little stuffed animals just really
creepy stuff good job creepy movie good
prey on those most in need now a major
problem I have with this film I can't
really get into too much because it is a
spoiler so without spoiling anything I
will say that the way the film concludes
kind of negates the last 20 minutes or
so of the movie it makes it seem like
why did we just go through all that if
that was going to happen without
spoiling anything I'll just say that it
seemed like it kind of made the last 20
minutes of the movie completely
unnecessary but this is a good transfer
from Harry Potter to other films from
Radcliffe because he's able to keep that
fantasy audience that's into you know
that whole world I hope his career goes
Lok's I like him in this movie I want to
see him do more this was a fun suspense
film with some very effective moments
and really good use of tension
all-in-all I enjoyed the woman in black
a lot and I'm going to give it a B
what is your all-time favorite scary
movie can you decide what it is I'd like
to know if you'd like this review you
can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck mine eyes